for today's classic interview we are
going to an interview I did a couple of
years ago about two and a half years ago
with mark Hyden and mark Hyden is
against the death penalty but what was
interesting about mark Hyden is that
he's part of a group called
conservatives against the death penalty
and I thought it'd be interesting to
check out that interview especially now
in the context of Donald Trump talking
about wanting to execute drug dealers
and actually expand use of the death
penalty also in the context of all the
problem problems that many states have
been having getting the drugs that are
often used in these lethal executions
lethal injection executions and Oklahoma
as we talked about on the bonus show
last week using nitrogen gas for these
executions let's go back to why even by
conservative standards as mark Hyden
pointed out to us and made abundantly
clear back in August of 2015 the death
penalty is something that as a developed
Western nation we should be running away
from and slowly but surely we are going
in that direction the question is will
we and if and when we will get to a ban
in all 50 states on the death penalty I
think that there will probably be some
holdouts there my interview with mark
Hyden I'm joined today by mark Hyden
who's the national advocacy coordinator
with conservatives concerned about the
death penalty he comes most recently
from the National Rifle Association
where he was campaign field
representative in the state of Florida
you know mark I think this is probably
the first time on the show that we're
having a former NRA person on because we
just agree with you so much from the
conservative side and I think
increasingly people are understanding
that there's really nothing very
conservative about the death penalty is
there well you're absolutely correct
when you look at the death penalty and
you look at what principles
conservatives hold dear
they just don't line up conservatives
believe in pro-life policies but the
death penalty risks innocent life
conservatives also believe in fiscal
responsibility and restraint but the
death penalty is far more expensive than
life without parole and it's even led to
tax increases and we also believe in
limited government but I don't believe
there's anything limited or wise about
giving an error-prone state the power to
kill its citizens
so I think it's antithetical to
conservative principles and this idea of
the the government having as little
involvement as possible if we sort of
think of the conservative idea of the
government should take the smallest
action possible to have the the best
possible outcome I was recently looking
at a study showing that harsher
sentences including the death penalty do
not actually have a deterrent effect on
crime and do not actually improve the
sort of status quo around crime so why
would the government take what I think
we would all agree is a bigger action
right the putting to death of someone if
we are not even getting that desired
impact of either deterrence or whatever
else it may be well conservatives like
to do cost-benefit analyses and I like
to do the same so I asked myself for a
big broken government program like the
death penalty that has a high human and
fiscal cost what do we get out of this
what's our bang for the buck and
truthfully we don't get much you're
right the death penalty does not deter
murder the state side of the perennial
leaders and executions actually have the
highest murder rates and if you look at
states like New York and New Jersey
their murder rates actually went down
once they repeal the death penalty but
if you go beyond public safety because
we know the death penalty doesn't deter
you also are confronted with the fact
that the system is very harmful on
murder victims friends and family
members because the long drawn-out
process and the incessant media
attention there's another way you know I
read about your position on how the
death penalty fails the families of the
victims I think there's another way to
consider also which is that when you say
well certain types of crimes are worthy
of the death penalty and others that may
appear just as heinous but maybe it
doesn't involve a multiple murder it was
just a single murder doesn't it in a
sense risk devaluing the sort of the the
victims of what has been determined to
be a crime that's not quite bad enough
for the death penalty but bad enough for
life without parole it starts to sort of
categorize the different victims and
affect their families as well it does
and conservatives you know we pride
ourselves on valuing life
but that kind of valuation is
inappropriate it's saying some lives are
worth more than others and that's how
the death penalty works it's very
arbitrary if you look at the the race of
the victim if it's a white person who
may or may not have been murdered by a
person of color there's a higher
likelihood that it's going to turn out
as a death penalty case as opposed to
life without parole and that goes back
to you know Liberty or excuse me Lady
Justice is supposed to be blind but
apparently she's not colorblind so let's
talk a little bit about what you think
as someone who is working within the
conservative world as to why the death
penalty is so appealing to many on the
right at broadly I've talked about this
idea that it that exists on the right
with regard to many social policies of
sort of strict father morality as George
Lakoff has put it which is we're gonna
put aside for a second as you said the
the cost-benefit analyses we're going to
put aside for a second the facts on
deterrence because sometimes we just
have this innate sense that people
deserve to be punished in a way that we
see fit am I on to something there is
there's some other explanation that you
see as to why so many on the right
really like the death penalty I had a
conversation at the North Carolina GOP
convention someone came up to me and
they said you know I support the death
penalty because I think that some people
just deserved to die I said I told them
I'm not gonna argue with that line of
thinking that's your own opinion but do
you trust an error-prone government to
fairly efficiently and properly
administer this program when you don't
trust it to deliver a piece of mail and
the light bulb went off in his head and
he walked away being against the death
penalty we have to look at this program
not in a theoretical framework but how
our government actually operates it and
it operates it in a very very flawed
fashion is that in your mind the best
way speaking as a conservative who has
convinced other conservatives that the
death penalty is a bad idea
is taking a sort of we don't trust the
government approach the best way to
change other conservatives mind on this
because there's so many arguments that
could be made right there's the cost
argument there's the risk of innocent
life argument and we've seen increased
data that suggests one out of twenty
five on death row is not guilty of the
crime they've been convicted of what in
your mind is is the best argument and
maybe that one is it which is listen we
don't trust the government and and we
don't want them putting the death
penalty on anybody
well I found that one to be very
convincing but for me is the
preponderance of the evidence
I used to support the death penalty but
once I looked at it in a conservative
framework and I noticed all of the
problems all of them together is what
pushed me to finally come out against
the death penalty and you know each
person is different some people are led
by the cost arguments which I'm a fiscal
conservative as well but others are not
swayed by that but they're swayed by the
life issues or just their distrust of
government so every person is different
but there's there's no shortage of
reasons to oppose the death penalty
Nebraska is a recent conservative state
that has repealed the death penalty and
your organization played a role there
what is it that you do on the ground to
try to get a repeal going I mean what
are the sort of logistics involved well
it takes years of planning and our
involvement in Nebraska was part of a
broader coalition so there are a lot of
different organizations that were
involved and it went on for years they
were working with legislators persuading
them showing them the information about
the death penalty but they're also
working and I was working as well with
the grass roots and grass tops in
Nebraska to get them to contact their
legislators and let them know which way
they should be voting they should be
voting the way they're conscious they
should be voting the way of their
principles and after years of pushing
towards this Nebraska finally repealed
the death penalty they did so by
overturning a filibuster as well as a
veto override and became the first red
state number forty years to repeal the
death penalty so what can individuals do
who still live in states with the death
penalty is starting with their most
local of legislators the way to go
writing to senators and and us members
of Congress well you know I'm a
conservative and I'd like to think that
politics is best done on a local level
on a state-by-state legislative basis
and that's our focus is to try to repeal
the death penalty at the state level
because that's that's where it's used
the most only three people have been
executed at the federal level in the
modern era so mainly it comes from the
state level especially
these states like Texas so I recommend
you know they contact me go to our
website sign up and also reach out to
their state representatives and state
legislators and start a grassroots
movement in their own local areas is
there some hope even though as you say
most of these decisions are made at the
state level that we could see what
happened with marriage equality happened
with the death penalty which is at a
certain point it becomes very clear that
at the state level there is this
preponderance of desire so to speak
across the country to say no more death
penalty where there might be some sort
of federal or Supreme Court ruling on it
I guess the question would be what kind
of a case could broadly challenge the
death penalty to the supreme court
that's where I see sort of a tough hill
to climb but is there some possibility
of federal action on this I mean there's
always a chance I mean capital cases are
going to the Supreme Court with
regularity and yeah since Justice
Roberts has been put in place I've given
up on trying to figure out which way
they're gonna rule on anything so it's
always a possibility that the Supreme
Court will weigh in recently they looked
at the Glossop case having to do with
the potential of cruel and unusual
punishment and some of the more
left-leaning justices came out and
pretty much opposed to the death penalty
and state of the many reasons why they
can't support it regardless of that
individual case so there's always the
possibility that in the coming years
that a Supreme Court ruling may come
down and in the death penalty nationally
last thing I want to touch on as a
conservative who on this particular
issue sides more with this sort of
prevailing left-leaning opinion in the
US on what other issues do you find
yourself having maybe more natural
allies on the left well you know we're
single issue organizations so I know but
you personally I mean oh me personally
well you know I believe in limited
government and I've and sometimes that
means that I align more with
libertarians as well as some on the left
you know I I there's a multitude of
issues that could come out from that but
when it comes to my voting it's usually
pretty much or it's always on the
Republican line yeah that I'm not at all
surprised to hear all right we've been
speaking with mark Hyden he's the
national advocate
the coordinator with conservatives
concerned about the death penalty thank
you so much for talking to us about this
David thanks for having me on